et on est incapable d'en prendre
conscience mais ce n'est pas de
pessimistes nous comprendre ce qui va
arriver pour moi je pense qu'on est
comme une guerre aujourd'hui on est
entré en guerre contre nos façons de vue
et les demis y en n'a pas d'ennemi
l'ennemi c'est nous
[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur arte et
france pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec à nos invités toujours tenus à
bonne distance et nos reporters sur le
terrain voici les types de ce mercredi
emmanuel macron s'adressera aux français
dimanche à 20h à la proche d'une
nouvelle étape de déconfinement prévue
pour le 22 juin et au moment où les
appels à accélérer le processus se
multiplient dans le pays
en attendant le gouvernement déploie
près de 45 milliards d'euros en soutien
au secteur fragilisé
quant à l'état d'urgence sanitaire il ne
devrait pas être prolongé au-delà du 10
juillet la gestion des crises sanitaires
une enquête ouverte par le parquet de
paris vise à déterminer d'éventuelles
infractions pénales
la responsabilité des membres du
gouvernement sera elle jugé par la cour
de justice de la république qui a reçu à
ce jour 80 plaintes sur le sujet alors
faut-il une cour spéciale pour juger les
ministres ou les anciens ministres ce
sera l'objet de notre face à face tout à
l'heure au sahel les exactions contre
les populations locales augmentent
amnesty international tire la sonnette
d'alarmé dans un rapport révélant une
autre facette de la guerre victimes de
groupes terroristes les populations
seraient aussi la cible de soldats sous
pression notamment au mali au niger et
au burkina faso
le quai d'orsay salue les ouvertures
donc est annoncé par les autorités
syriennes
[Musique]
aux états unis deux frères de georges
frêche et implore le congrès de mettre
un terme à la souffrance des afro
américains quels changements à venir
dans le pays encore sous le coup de
l'émotion la lutte antiraciste s'invite
dans la campagne présidentielle
l'heure de la justice raciale est venu a
martelé hier joe biden dans une vidéo
diffusée lors des obsèques de l'homme
tué par le policier le 25 mai dernier
[Musique]
les conséquences de la crise sanitaire
et la rainette de l'économie durant deux
mois les prévisions économiques pour
cette année ne sont pas bonnes du tout
il faut s'attendre à un recul du pib de
11% au lieu de 8 et 800 mille
suppressions d'emplois les prochains
mois ce qui pousse le gouvernement à
revoir son budget face à la crise était
ce matin en conseil des ministres 45
milliards en plus donc pour les secteurs
les plus fragilisés ce qui devrait
porter le soutien public à 460 milliards
d'euros
il s'agit du troisième projet de loi de
finances rectificative - 11 % pour
l'année 2020 la gravité de cette
récession
elle appelle une réponse massive ce
temps nous amène à soutenir avec ce
projet de loi de finances un certain
nombre de secteurs qui sont les plus
menacés et avec eux des centaines de
milliers d'emplois l'ensemble de ces
mesures représente 45 milliards d'euros
en soutien à des secteurs qui sont de le
redis les plus touchés par la crise
la logique de ces interventions c'est
protéger les emplois c'est aussi
accélérer la transformation de ce
secteur
nous voulons que ces secteurs puissent
se digitalise et ce robotisés nous
voulons que les pme les sous traitants
puisse accélérer notre transformation
économique parce qu'il s'agit pas
simplement de sauver notre capital
humain et notre capital d'entreprises
il s'agit aussi de préparer l'après
crise et avoir un tissu industriel un
tissu économique qui soit le plus
performant possible
ouais le bilan du coran navires faisant
l'hexagone le nombre de cas graves en
réanimation poursuit sa baisse avec 933
cas contre 955 hier selon la direction
générale de la santé qui précise qu'il
n'y a pas de signe de reprise épidémique
la france enregistré 23 morts liés aux
kobe 19 dans les hôpitaux
ces dernières 24 heures au total 29
mille trois cent dix neuf personnes sont
mortes depuis le
début de l'épidémie et pour revenir sur
la situation sanitaire lié aux vies nous
sommes en direct avec le professeur yves
buisson épidémiologistes membre de
l'académie de médecine
bonsoir professeur lui sont merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france ces
chiffres évidemment très encourageant de
la part de la direction de la santé 1 ce
soir il n'y a pas de reprise visible de
l'épidémie qu'est ce qu'on peut en
conclure bien ces chiffres sont donc les
chiffres que vous venez de présenter son
d indicateur tardif
l'indicateur de admission en réanimation
et l'indicateur de décès sont très
tardif par rapport au temps de
l'infection donc bien sûr ils sont
encourageants mais il faut regarder
plutôt les indicateurs précoces c'est à
dire le nombre de nouveaux cas de kobe
de 19 qui sont déclarés est bon ils
diminuent également
mais probablement à si vite que ce que
l'on pourrait espérer
et il faut également regarder le nombre
de nouveaux foyers ce qu'on appelle les
clusters ces nouveaux foyers il y en a
et elle a beaucoup voyagé beaucoup il y
en a il y en a c'est d'un côté il ya une
c'est une bonne nouvelle dans la mesure
où on sait les repérer on sait les
détecter et on arrive la plupart du
temps à les contrôler dira les
circonscrire à éviter que à partir de
ces foyers se développent de petits des
épidémies local ou régional mais il
existe toujours ce qui signifie que le
virus continue de circuler dans la
population française dans toutes les
régions de la halle de france et qu' il
n'est pas encore question de considérer
que l'épidémie est terminée
l'épidémie est enfoui en voie
d'achèvement
mais elle n'est pas terminée donc il
faut encore prescrire les mesures
barrières un respect très strict de ces
mesures
même s'il en coûte un peu à eux mêmes
beaucoup à certains de nos compatriotes
qui aimerait reprendre la vie d'avant
alors effectivement on note ces foyers
notamment en loire atlantique
dans une école dans deux foyers l'a
handicapé l'autre de mineurs à arles
également comment vous les expliquez
vous ces foyers docteur mais on les
explique par le fait donc ses siv a vu
la circulation du virus qui il faut se
rappeler que de la particularité de
cette maladie virale c'est qu'il ya un
grand nombre de formes asymptomatiques
ou très peu symptomatiques donc des
formes qui passe inaperçu ce sont ces
personnes qui tout en gardant une vie
sociale à peu près normal tenir en sorte
en ayant des contacts et bien vont
propager le virus
et ça c'est très difficile à détecter
alors que dans d'autres maladies on
aurait pu les détecter parce que bon les
gens étaient malades dont ils ne
sortaient pas ils étaient bloqués chez
eux
cette circulation elle se manifeste de
temps en temps justement par un foyer et
dans ses foyers il faut qu'ils aient
bien sûr des conditions propices pour la
propagation qui est des gens qu'ils
soient qu'ils vivront on a vu que dans
le cas des abattoirs par exemple il y
avait des conditions qui étaient tout à
fait favorables à la dissémination du
virus parce que les gens travaillaient
dans des conditions très de promiscuité
et de température qui est favoriser la
dissémination du virus les domaines les
et les écoles et les collectivités
quelles qu'elles soient sont des
endroits qui sont des révélateurs de la
circulation du virus
donc ce n'est pas étonnant de voir que
ce sont dans ces endroits que survienne
la plupart des foyers
la difficulté c'est effectivement de les
circonscrire donc de les détecter le
plus tôt possible grâce à l'utilisation
des tests maintenant on a suffisamment
de tests pour le faire est de repérer
par le traçage toutes les personnes qui
ont pu être en contact avec les cas de
façon à les tester à leur tour et elle
est isolée si c'est nécessaire vous
l'avais dit il ya des foyers il ya des
nouveaux camps plus que l'on espérait
mais les chiffres d'admissions à
l'hôpital semble marquer le pas en être
en baisse ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que finalement le virus est moins
virulent qu'avant où on ne peut pas
tirer cette conclusion
non le virus est toujours aussi virulent
je pense qu'il n'a pas évolué depuis
plusieurs semaines mais les diminutions
d'entrée comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure dans le service à l'hôpital et
dans le service de réanimation
traduisent des infections qui ont eu
lieu il ya deux trois semaines
la diminution du taux de mortalité
traduire des infections qui sont
survenus il ya trois semaines un mois ou
peut-être plus d'un mois donc mais sur
ce sont des indicateurs très
encourageant mais ce qu'il faut
maintenant c'est agir sur les nouvelles
infections
il faut diminuer les nouvelles
infections il faut puisqu'il faut faire
en sorte que le virus cessent de
circuler
alors on était d un peu en cela par par
l'arrivée des beaux jours on va arriver
donc la saison d'été où la chaleur ne
peut aider à lutter contre la
transmission
bien sûr nos mesures barrières elles
sont toujours très très efficace mais si
le climat peut nous aider à passer ce
sera extrêmement appréciable dans la
mesure où ça permettra de favoriser
l'arrêt définitif de la circulation du
virus
il faut aller vers cet arrêt définitif
vous répondez presque à ma question
parce que j'allais vous demander cette
baisse des chiffres selon vous est ce
qu'elle est due justement au respect des
gestes barrières parce qu'on a vu quand
même hein
voilà tous devant nos écrans de
télévision ici même
qui a eu des rassemblements ici ou là
des matchs sauvage des manifestations
donc est ce qu'elle est due au respect
des gestes barrières ou est ce qu'elle
est due à la disparition tout simplement
d'épidémie comme le prédisait didier
rahout une épidémie saisonnière qui est
en train de partir comme elle est venue
oui elle est bien sûr aux deux facteurs
mais actuellement 20 depuis quelques
semaines depuis surtout le la date du 11
mai on constate qu'il ya eu une levée
progressive des mesures de confinement
ce qui fait que un certain nombre de
personnes ont considéré que c'était fini
les mesures de distanciation le port du
masque on a un petit peu oublié il ya
les grands rassemblements auxquels vous
auquel vous faites allusion qui sont
catastrophiques sur le plan
épidémiologique parce que là ce sont des
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui se
rassemblent alors que c'est interdit et
qui échange si l on si elles sont
porteuses du virus qui échangent des
virus parce qu'on peut pas faire
autrement dans ce type de rassemblement
où l'on crie où on vaporise des airs au
sol avec à partir de sa bouche il ne
peut pas en être autrement qu'il y aura
des risques de contamination dans ces
rassemblements et que par ailleurs et
bien on interdit les rassemblements
sportifs ou culturels
c'est un petit peu incohérent 1 ce qui
se passe mais il est probable que cesser
ce relâchement qui agit probablement
pour dans le sens que la diminution la
fin de l'épidémie n'est peut-être pas
aussi rapides qu'elles le devraient
alors que le climat agit lui dans le bon
sens le climat favorise l'arrêt de
l'épidémie et le professeur out sur ce
plan là du moins était tout à fait dans
le vrai puisque la cette affection à
corona virus est une affection qui sera
saisonnière même si au début c'était une
pandémie elle s'est répandue dans le
monde un peu indépendamment des saisons
dans lesquels se trouvaient les
différents pays du monde merci
professeur lui sont d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france membre de
l'académie de médecine merci à vous une
enquête ouverte par le parquet de paris
à propos de la gestion de la crise du
corps d'un virus en france celle-ci vise
à déterminer d'éventuelles infractions
pénales
la responsabilité des membres du
gouvernement sera une jugées par la cjr
la cour de justice de la république a
reçu à ce jour 80 plaintes sur le sujet
zoom sur cette institution en images
[Rires]
où
[Musique]
[Rires]
on
monde
oh
[Musique]
on
alors la cour de justice de la
république est elle appropriée dans ce
cas de figure faut-il une cour spéciale
pour juger les ministres ou les anciens
ministres ou plutôt une justice de droit
commun pour des hommes aux parcours peu
commun c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir et pour en débattre
nous sommes en direct avec fabrice di
vizio avocat du collectif c 19 bonsoir
fabrice di vizio vous représentez de
nombreux soignants qui ont déposé
plainte précisément contre le
gouvernement pour la gestion de cette
crise du coronavirus pour débattre avec
vous philippe gosselin la liaison
manifestement skype c'est un peu
compliqué ce soir ça nous contraint être
en direct par téléphone seulement avec
philippe gosselin député l ère de la
manche qui est juge titulaire justement
à la cour de justice de la république
vous avez été élu à cette fonction
novembre 2017 par l'assemblée nationale
dont soit philippe gosselin merci d'être
en direct avec 11 morts et plus de lait
pour cette liaison entre calpe qu'il
marchait très bien à 19h15 quand on a
fait l'été voilà on va vous n'êtes pas
coupable du réseau français
enfin philippe gosselin on va essayer de
débattre oui oui c'est vrai on aurait
bien aimé moi aussi vous vous voir à
l'écran face à fabrice division mais
n'hésitez pas en tout cas à débattre
avec lui ont néanmoins alors cette mini
sept ministres jugés en en 27 ans
d'existence plus d'équipements que deux
condamnations
alors cette cour spéciale on s'est
parfois controversés on dénonce souvent
une une justice à deux vitesses françois
hollande voulait d'ailleurs la supprimer
lorsqu'il était président finalement il
ne l'a pas fait très décriée vous en
avez conscience justement on imagine un
philippe gosselin oui tout à fait bon
moi je ne mourrai pas pour la cour de
justice je vous dis tout de suite
maintenant il faut peut-être prendre le
temps de réfléchir un peu à ceux qui
réellement cette institution et et son
intérêt on rappellera quand même que
1793 pas comment s'adapter mais c'est
l'époque révolutionnaire jusqu'en 1993
est quand même assez restants ou
les ministres avait une immunité
complète où il était jugé uniquement par
le parlement donc la cour de justice de
la république en 93 quand elle a été
instituée au moment de l' affaire du
sang contaminé c'était réellement un
plus qui permettait qui permet de juger
les ministres pour des crimes ou des
délits commis dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions donc il ya il ya quelques
petites dizaines d'années c'était un
vrai plus maintenant le système est loin
d'être parfait j'en conviens mais pour
voir par quoi on le remplace parce que
je crois que sans vouloir défendre à
tout prix les ministres ont un exécutif
en particulier les fonctions
ministérielles ne sont pas tout à fait
le droit commun pas tout à fait
équivalent d'un délit d'un crime entre
guillemets classiques n'ont semble-t-il
fabrice di vizio d'accord avec le
diagnostic justement de philippe
boesmans est pas comparable à un crime
de droit commun
monsieur gosselin se trompent pardonnez
moi monsieur gosselin a contre lui
le droit ce qui est d'exception c'est la
justice
la juridiction pas le délit les
ministres sont jugés pour des délits de
droit commun pour des délits relevant du
code pénal comme vous et moi
mais dans une des conditions compatibles
avec l'exercice de leurs missions et à
six de la prérogative par une justice
d'exception
le débat n'est pas de savoir s'il faut
remettre en cause les conditions du
droit commun la con direct le débat est
de savoir s'il faut que ces délits
ordinaires soit jugé par une juridiction
extraordinaire c'est un autre débat et 2
fait ce que dit monsieur gosselin enfin
juste sur le constat c'est à dire que
c'est un progrès cette cote de zizou a
public faux pas faut pas bouder son
plaisir non plus vient il ya
effectivement un vrai progrès on a mis
du temps à faire émerger il a émergé il
est pas parfait ce système et il doit
être réformé
ça me paraît évident on met notamment la
réforme qui doit absolument et
remise aujourd'hui à l'ordre du jour
c'est le fait qu' il ne faut pas qu'il y
ait de parlementaires dans cette cour il
n'y a aucune raison que la fonction
judiciaire que l'autorité judiciaire qui
est distincte du pouvoir législatif soit
venu soit quelque part en veille par
celui ci soit envahie par le législateur
le législateur juge ça n'existe pas
c'est une réminiscence finalement de
cette haute cour où on a fait le chemin
à moitié ayons l'audace de venir
consacrer une juridiction d'exception
pourquoi pas mais avec des magistrats de
l'ordre judiciaire de bout en bout dont
c'est le métier dont c'est la fonction
constitutionnel fait beau ça sur ce
diagnostic de réformes ou les
législateurs n'ont finalement rien à
faire dans cette cour qu'est ce que vous
répondez
j'ai quelques principes sur lesquels ou
pour lesquelles je serai prêt à à
combattre mais je ne mourrai pas je les
lis pour la cour de justice de la
république qui est qui a bien bien des
faiblesses sans doute est en effet la
première c'est d'être une juridiction
d'exception et la le le coup et est
évidemment imparable maintenant il ne
faudrait pas laisser croire que c'est
une juridiction politiques qui gèrent
des affaires entre soi
on a certes des parlementaires six
députés et six sénateurs qui font partie
de la formation de jugement mais en
réalité cette formation de jugement elle
n'intervient éventuellement en bout de
chaîne
on a d'abord une commission
d'instruction avec trois juges
titulaires qui sont des dépôts
magistrats de la cour de cassation
on a ensuite en deuxième étage de la
fusée si l'on peut dire
la commission des requêtes avec des
magistrats du siège de la cour de
cassation deux conseillers d'état de
conseiller maître à la cour des comptes
et là il n'est pas du tout du tout
question à ce stade d'avoir une approche
deux parlementaires ou une approche
politique donc
ne laissons pas penser à celles et ceux
qui nous écoutent que les parlementaires
font la pluie et le beau temps dans
cette juridiction je crois que ça serait
totalement impropre et ailleurs dans les
plaintes qui ont été déposées
officiellement et clairement à aucun
moment les parlementaires ne sont dans
la boucle ne sont informés de quoi que
ce soit ce n'est que lorsqu'il
éventuellement la formation de jugement
aura voire à se réunir que les
parlementaires sont dans la boucle donc
voilà je n'ai pas totalement l'exception
à l'exception et il est bon de le
rappeler aussi alors je vais vous faire
réagir faire baiser vision vous donnera
là bas la parole je vois que vous avez
envie de réagir aux propos de de
philippe gosselin mais écoutez ses
déclarations récentes de patrick
maisonneuve un patrick maisonneuve c'est
l'ex avocate christine lagarde l'ancien
ministre de la finance un vous en
souvenez devant la crj au moment de
l'arbitrage en 2008 de l' affaire
tapie/crédit l'onu lyonnais interrogé il
ya quelques jours sur la multiplication
des plaintes contre le gouvernement la
question est ce qu'on recherche un
coupable ou la justice écoutez sa
réponse
c'est une soif de coupables on a déjà
vécu dans les années 1990 au moment de
l' affaire du sang contaminé
je retrouve cette situation où c'est la
recherche à tout prix de responsabilité
pédales et individuelles je crois que
l'on confond absolument tout c'est la
recherche d'un coupable pénale à tout
prix et je regrette d'ailleurs qu'un
certain nombre d'avocats se prête à ces
initiatives d'engager des procédures
pénales sur un sujet qui ne l'est pas
alors fabrice di vizio vous êtes en
quelque sorte visé puisque vous êtes en
ce week end c'est justement de ces
plaintes qu'est ce que vous répondez
à cet homme patrick maisonneuve qui vous
dire en gros vous recherchez absolument
un coupable
non seulement je suis en soutien mais je
suis le premier à avoir fait les
premières plaintes c'est nous qui les
avons faites
je suis le premier chronologiquement
avant déposer ses pelotes et à patrick
de maisons d'hommes je répond ceci
n'avez vous pas l'impression cher
confrère d'être un peu désavoué
aujourd'hui votre propos à l'heure où le
parquet lui considère qu'il ya matière
pénale le parquet vient ouvrir des
enquêtes chapeau préliminaire
pourriez-vous encore soutenir que ça
n'est pas pénal quand effectivement à
madame lagarde est la recherche de
coupables
vous avez défendu madame lagarde est ce
qu effectivement cette recherche de
coupables
eh bien avec avait propos sur cette
question ce que nous cherchons dans la
justice pénale ça n'est jamais la
recherche de coûts passent la recherche
de la vérité
et j'ajoute que là où le propos de
maître maisonneuve traduit quand même
quelque chose d'assez caractéristiques
de cette crise c'est que nous sommes
dans une espèce d'auberge espagnole où
tout le monde fait tout sauf qu'ils
devraient faire
moi je fais du droit moi j'ai le droit
de saisir la cour de 6,2 république je
le fais je ne cherche pas de coupable
c'est faux je veux dire j'ai un respect
profond pour la présomption d'innocence
qui fait que vous ne m'avez jamais
entendu dire que qui que ce soit et
coupables pourraient potentiellement le
maître et j'ai même dit je vais aller
plus loin puisque j'ai même dit que je
me réjouirais si effectivement au terme
de l'instruction il devait s'avérer que
finalement il n'y ait pas de délit pénal
parce que ce serait heureux pour le
fonctionnement de la démocratie donc il
faut pas compter sur moi et venir me
faire faire un procès politique dans
cette affaire celui qui fait de la
politique c'est celui qui tient ces
propos et qui effectivement sait
pertinemment pourtant que le droit nous
permet de le faire et que l'avocat
finalement ne nous y trompons pas et
auxiliaires de justice
mais j'ajoute un point rapide si oui je
réagisse que visible sur le plan moteur
jeu reflète que quand même c'est une
juridiction d'apparatchiks soyons
d'accord
la cour de justice de la république est
une juridiction d'apparatchiks et en
témoignent les condamnations qu'elles à
prononcer les trois condamnations
qu'elle a prononcées sont sans commune
mesure avec celle qui pour les mêmes
délits
regardez dans
la ministre de la justice avec la
violation du secret professionnel et
monsieur thierry solère les contrats
condamnations prononcées pour les
socioprofessionnels et dérisoire nous
dans notre profession d avocat jeté en
prison pour ça donc on vienne pas me
dire que cette justice être autre chose
que cette prédiction autre chose que de
lecture d'apparatchiks vous n'êtes pas
tellement équipements cher maître queux
tas devrait rapidement envie de mourir
pour la cour de lui si je voulais dire
moi je cherche pas à dépendre à tout
prix un système qui était en 93 une
amélioration par rapport à aline existe
encore une fois il faut bien avoir en
tête qui se faisait à cette époque et
depuis la révolution c'était ou une
impunité totale
une immunité totale ou un jugement par
le parlement lui-même
aujourd'hui la cour de justice existe on
fait avec et je n'oublie pas qu'il ya eu
des projets de réforme
ceci étant la révision constitutionnelle
de 2008 pour le moment patiner et je
pense qu'elle ne verra pas le jour
donc la révision et la suppression de la
cour de justice de la république n'est
plus vraiment d'actualité
mais dans tous les cas il n'était pas
question et beaucoup de juristes
d'ailleurs d'accord pour dire que c'est
plutôt bien il n'était pas question de
donner à des tribunaux classiques les
compétences en matière de jugement de
ministres en exercice et il était prévu
dans le projet d'avoir la cour d'appel
de paris qui te resterait compétente
après une question d'incrimination
qualification juridique des faits est en
effet au droit pénal et je ne peux pas
vous dire autre chose au droit de
poursuivre son oeuvre et si culpabilité
il y à qui la commission d'instruction
transmet à la commission des requêtes
via la sphère suivra son cours et je
peux vous dire que je n'ai pas d'états
d'âme et nous serons en notre âme et
conscience comme tous les magistrats
notre travail de moment venu ça me
paraît bien la moindre des choses dans
un état de droit
merci fabrice di vizio et merci à vous
également philippe gosselin en espérant
la prochaine fois qu'on pourra vous voir
apparaître également dans cet écran pour
débattre avec mon merci
d'avoir été en direct sur rt france dans
quelques instants nous partirons au sel
un rapport d'amnesty international alert
sur les exactions commises par les
forces armées sur les populations
locales notamment au burkina faso au
niger ou encore au mali et puis
direction les états unis au lendemain
des obsèques de georges floyd plusieurs
villes et états ont des propositions
pour limiter le financement de la police
et améliorer ses pratiques
[Musique]
comme d'habitude on rajoute de la dette
parce qu'on aime ça
on aime beaucoup la bête pour la
première fois on parle une tête commune
à messieurs simples tout à fait nouveau
est-ce que vous pensez que vous avez des
gens qui dans aux pays bas ou en france
vont vouloir aller payer des impôts pour
les grecs tout pour les italiens alors
monsieur moto place à l'italie et à
l'espagne sont allés principaux
bénéficiaires c'est un message fort
selon vous envoyez à ces pays du sud qui
se joue dans cette histoire c'est la
marche en avant tous les pays de toute
l'europe l'europe est morte
enfin acté kelly morte
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on a une idée d'augmentation
ou pas des signes ici d'aujourd'hui en
france l'écho et les violences existait
avant le confinement et pendant ce
confinement c'est vrai qu'il ya sept ce
cadre lecture les taux des féminicides a
plus que je dis pas doublé mais bien
monté forcément on n'a pas encore tous
les chiffres officiels c'est très
difficile bourreau n'est jamais n'est
jamais loin finalement c'est le
confinement dans le confinement
cela veut dire qu'il ya huit clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément dans les femmes victimes de
violences le nombre en 3 à 3
[Musique]
l'histoire est plus compliquée que
certains veulent nous le faire croire
vouloir à la réécrire pour faire oublier
les échecs ne permet pas de comprendre
ce qui s'est vraiment passé
c'est ainsi que dans certains manuels de
cours d'histoire de nos enfants on veut
faire oublier napoléon bonaparte grand
organisateur de l'état moderne pour
profit de robespierre
le père de la terreur j'ai écouté le
président très pratique et le déni en
oubliant carrément l'allier qui a eu le
triste privilège d'avoir le plus grand
nombre de morts dans la deuxième garde
mais si j'ai bien compris ils sont morts
pour rien puisque au nom d'une idéologie
on nie leur existence en oubliant une
partie de la game
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre en
direct sur rt france il est 20h30 heure
de paris au sahel au moins 200 civils
auraient été la cible d'exactions de la
part des forces armées de plusieurs pays
de la région entre février et avril 2020
c'est ce que révèle un rapport
d'amnistié internationale qui recense
des témoignages auprès de populations au
mali au niger et au burkina faso thomas
bonnet pour les explications cela fait
des années que le sahel est en proie à
un conflit armé particulièrement
éprouvant pour les populations locales
des groupes djihadistes opère notamment
dans ces cinq pays désormais regroupées
sous l'appellation g5 celle une
structure appuyée par la présence des
forces militaires françaises à travers
l'opération barkan parmi les missions de
ce g5 sahel se trouve la coordination
des forces militaires locales pour faire
face aux groupes armés
c'est l'un des aspects les plus délicats
de cette opération la formation et la
montée en compétence des armées locales
et ce ne sont pas les révélations
d'amnesty international qui vont
contribuer à l'amélioration du climat
sur place selon un rapport de l'ol j'ai
entre février et avril de cette année
les forces de défense et de sécurité au
mali au burkina faso et au niger se
serait rendu coupable d'un certain
nombre d'exactions 199 incidents sont
répertoriés dans le document 57 cas
d'exécutions extrajudiciaires ou
d'homicides illégaux ont été relevés et
142 cas de disparitions forcées ont été
constatés amnesty international publie
ainsi des témoignages d'habitants qui
ont subi ces exactions
parmi les nombreux récits que l'on peut
lire il y a notamment celui qui revient
sur la journée du 7 février dernier où
une patrouille des forces de sécurité
maliennes se rend dans le village de
massat bogou selon le rapport 22
personnes auraient été arrêtées et huit
autres auraient été exécutés par les
soldats voici ce que raconte un témoin
ils les membres des forces de sécurité
et de défense sont arrivés dans le
village vers 17h tirs en l'air et
arrêtant des villageois de nombreuses
personnes ont fui ou sont restés dans
leurs maisons après l'arrivée des
soldats ils ont passé les maison au
peigne fin et
exécuter de manière extrajudiciaire huit
villageois et emmener les autres le
document expose de nombreux récits
similaires au niger et au burkina faso
une situation qui pourrait être
sous-estimée et qui a un impact
considérable sur la situation des
populations locales déjà menacée par la
présence de groupes armés de gea liste
l'insécurité règne celle où la
population est piégé entre les attaques
des groupes armés les opérations
militaires en cours
on sait que l'armée procède à chaque
fois des dizaines d'arrestations
arbitraires et que certaines des
personnes arrêtées ne réapparaisse
jamais mais on ignore l'ampleur réelle
des violations commises par les forces
de sécurité amnesty international se dit
très préoccupé par ces violations des
droits humains
llorente demande l'ouverture d' enquêtes
et le cas échéant la suspension des
personnes concernées mais elle demande
aussi aux partenaires des pays en
question d'appeler les autorités locales
à faire respecter le droit international
humanitaire
pour certains ces agissements découle de
manière plus ou moins directe du sommet
du g5 celle qui s'est tenue en janvier
dernier à pau c'est ce qu'explique
ousmane diallo chercheur à amnesty
international
il y as certainement une pression
politique auprès des armées du mali du
niger et du burkina et cela se traduit
naturellement par un relâchement de
leurs méthodes opératoires notamment ce
qui concerne le respect du droit humain
et le droit international humanitaire
à en croire les différentes enquêtes
menées ces derniers mois ces agissements
fautifs serait en hausse
une situation particulièrement alarmante
car elle est susceptible de renforcer
l'instabilité dans la région déjà rongé
par la menace djihadiste jusqu'à présent
l'opinion publique se montrait
particulièrement véhémente contre les
forces militaires étrangères notamment
l'armée française avec la révélation de
ces exactions cette défiance pourrait se
diriger aussi vers les forces armées
locales et compliquer encore davantage
une opération déjà très délicate et le
quai d'orsay a réagi par rapport à ce
rapport d'amnésie d'amnesty
international la france se dit préoccupé
par les allégations d'exactions à
l'encontre des populations civiles au
sahel
elle salue les ouvertures donc est
annoncé par les autorités s'est il y ait
des appels
à ce que les responsables présumés de
tels actes soient identifiés et traduits
en justice
pour en parler nous sommes avec françois
chauvancy général de brigade expert en
géostratégie bonsoir en soi choquant sli
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france on l'a entendue dans ce
sujet certains estiment que le dernier
sommet du g 500 en mettant la pression
sur les armées locales auraient pu
conduire un directement à ces
agissements ça vous paraît être une
bonne analyse
absolument pas je pense que c'est une
analyse qui est t on tait qui n'est pas
conforme à la réalité
le g5 c'est là pour mission de faire une
guerre de contre guérilla pour n'a
absolument pas avaliser des modes
d'action qui ne soit pas acceptable au
niveau du droit international ou
humanitaires donc il est un petit peu
simpliste de rattacher à cette
conférence internationale ailleurs
pilotée par la france des exactions sur
le terrain de troupes manifestement
plutôt mal commandé mal contrôlée comme
d'ailleurs c'est souvent le cas dans
toutes les actions de contre guérilla
dans les pays africains ou ailleurs ça
pose donc la question selon vous au
principalement de la formation de ses
forces armées de leur management entre
nîmes et oui tout à fait mais il faut
pas se faire d'illusions toutes les
armes et aujourd'hui reçoivent des cours
de droit international de respect des
populations de respect des conventions
de genève
ça c'est le premier point maintenant ce
sont des cours avec une application sur
le terrain temps de paix en temps de
guerre et ce qui est le cas justement
dans cette zone sahélienne
nous sommes dans une des actions de
guérilla bien entendu d'ailleurs c'est
dit dans le rapport un rapport comme qui
ne fait que 20 pages
ce rapport dit bien que ce sont plutôt
des réactions de troupeaux qui ont été
attaqués ou d'individus de militaires
réguliers qui ont été attaqués et qui
ont effectivement aurait plutôt mener
des actions de représailles
voilà bah c'est le cas dans toutes les
guerres c'est regrettable c'est
condamnable
le quai d'orsay s'est très bien exprimé
sur la question
ces actions ne sont pas tolérables
maintenant encore fauté toutes les
prouver et puis aussi peut-être un peu
comprendre le contexte 1007 se justifie
pas on imagine effectivement qu'on
évoquait au climat de tension qui doit
régner sur le terrain ah oui tout à fait
mais aujourd'hui cette guerre elle dure
cette guerre pèse de toute façon sur les
populations
les populations sont l'enjeu ce soit
pour les gouvernements locaux ou pour
les groupes terroristes
si vous reprenez le rapport d'amnesty
international il ya trois lignes sur les
groupes terroristes
il serait intéressant de savoir
exactement quels sont les exactions
qu'on connaît quand été commises contre
les populations par ces groupes
terroristes
or l'objet de ce rapport tel que moi je
les lui montrent que la cible ce sont
les états qui mènent la guerre contre
les terroristes et pas vraiment les
groupes terroristes
oui effectivement amnesty dit il
faudrait les poursuivre on sait bien
qu'on ne va pas les poursuivre donc
c'est une attaque en règle finalement
compté gouvernement et je pense que ce
rapport est un petit peu inégal dans son
approche
en quoi était inégale précisément ce
nouveau jt n'égale pas ce qui met la
pression sur les gouvernements ce qui
allait limite peut se comprendre mais il
demande au gouvernement d'agir
bon un grand terrain ne peut agir mais
cette guerre de terrorisme
mais quand même aux prises des groupes
armés qui massacrent les populations
c'est une réalité et qui ont massacré de
grandes quantités de population donc à
la limite si ce rapport avait bien
établie les faits de part et d'autre
pour les condamnés d'une avec la même
rigueur le même jugement
je pense que ce rapport serait tout à
fait acceptable en l'état
moi tels que je les lui la tel quel ce
que vous avez présenté il ya quelques
instants sur un analyste d'amnesty
international mais monde est certaine
partialité qui est assez courant
d'ailleurs dans ce type de rapport où on
met en cours d'abord les états avant de
ceux qui sont la cause des massacres en
l'occurrence ici des groupes terroristes
avec évidemment le danger de
décridibiliser l'armée les armées
locales voulaient dire sans doute un
oui mais bon les armées locales comme
dans tout pays en guerre et ces pays
africains ne sont pas toujours bien
accepté
il est certain que malgré des années de
formation dans ces armes et on voit bien
que tous les ce qu'on apprend armées
occidentales n'est pas appliquée ça on
le sait ensuite c'est sont désarmés qui
sont mis sous pression depuis des années
qui ont subi des pertes importantes
notamment au mali qui n'ont pas
forcément monter une grande rigueur dans
l'action militaire et qui finalement
sont dans une situation un petit peu de
déséquilibre face à un ennemi agressif
face à des populations qui subissent une
guerre et puis la recherche de ces
terroristes qu'il faut détruire et dans
toute guerre civile
assez disons les choses telles qu'elles
sont ce sont des guerres civiles en gros
dans leur principe la rochère du
renseignement les représailles
malheureusement font partie de ce genre
de guerre même s'il faut les dénoncer
même s'il faut condamner les auteurs
c'est une réalité qu'on ne peut pas
balayer d'un revers de main merci
beaucoup général france quoique souvent
si d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur
rt france l'actualité aux états unis
toujours dominé par le débat sur les
violences policières les démocrates à la
chambre des représentants et au sénat
ont dévoilé un projet de loi de réforme
radicale de la police aujourd'hui le
frère de john floyd a été entendu au
congrès pour appuyer la proposition de
loi si le texte passe
l'application des lois se ferait au
niveau national mais l'avenir du texte
risque d'être compromis au sénat à
majorité républicaine fillonistes floyd
est lui venu demander ce que l'on mette
un terme à la souffrance des
afro-américains écouter il était notre
gentil géant mais je m'en suis souvenu
lorsque j'ai regardé la vidéo de son
assassinat
il a appelé tous les officiers monsieur
il était doux il n'a pas répondu
il a écouté tous les officiers
l'homme qui lui a pris la vie de
l'étouffer pendant 8 minutes et 46
secondes
il a toujours appelé monsieur onem
lorsqu ils suppliaient pour sa vie
georgia appeler à l'aide
il a été ignoré veuillez aujourd'hui
écouter l'appel que je vous lance
maintenant les appels de notre famille
est les appels lancés dans les rues du
monde entier
des gens de tous les horizons de tous
les genres et de toutes les races se
sont réunis pour exiger le changement
aurélie famille de la victime les
proches vous venez de l'entendre espère
précisément que sa mort servira une
cause la fin du racisme et des violences
pital ils étaient plusieurs centaines
massés devant le cercueil de georges
floyd pour lui rendre un dernier hommage
cet homme afro américains tués lors de
son interpellation par la police a été
inhumé à houston la ville où elle a
grandi il cérémonie de plus de trois
heures lors de laquelle des messages
politiques se sont mêlés aux larmes
si quatre policiers noirs avaient faits
un homme blanc ce qui a été fait à
georges il n'y aurait pas besoin d'en
tirer des leçons qu'il n'aurait pas
besoin de convaincre les grandes
entreprises de donner de l'argent
il les aurait envoyés en prison et tant
que nous n'aurons pas compris qu'une vie
noir coûte le même prix qu'une vie
blanche
nous allons continuer à nous retrouver
confrontés à des situations comme celle
ci encore et encore
les proches du défunt ou eux salué celui
qui est surnommé big georges leur doux
géant ou encore superman la mort de
georges floyd a provoqué une
mobilisation inédite aux états unis et
les appelle à lutter contre les
inégalités raciales ont gagné le monde
entier comme s'en félicite l'avocat de
la famille
il ne s'agissait pas seulement de djorf
floyd de ligny mais avec respect il
s'agissait des générations futures
pour qu'elle sache que georges était une
personne comme chacun d'entre nous et
que si on fait ça à l'un d'entre nous
cela nous affecte tous c'était le
message aujourd'hui
pas un mot de la part de donald trump à
l'occasion de cette cérémonie il a au
contraire mis en cause la responsabilité
d'un homme de 75 ans poussé par des
policiers lors d'une manifestation
son rival à la présidentielle de 2000 20
joe biden s'est lui exprimé dans une
vidéo diffusée lors des obsèques
aujourd'hui c'est un moment où il est
nécessaire de prendre le temps d'écouter
et de réconcilier leurs de la justice
raciale est venu c'est la réponse que
nous devons donner à nos enfants lorsqu
ils nous demandent pourquoi parce que
lorsque justice sera rendue pour georges
floyd nous serons vraiment sur la voie
de la justice raciale en amérique
et alors comme tu l'as dit diana ton
papa aura changé le monde
un père de famille devenu un symbole
mondial des violences policières et
racistes dans le pays
partout dans le monde la mobilisation se
poursuit
des milliers de manifestants ont défilé
hier réclamant l'égalité pour les
minorités ethniques et la fin des
violences policières
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis chattanooga aux états unis avec
anthony brian logan blogueur politique
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir
[Musique]
un bon soir anthony browne logan merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
tout d'abord première question les
tensions sont telles bel et bien retombé
quelle est l'atmosphère aux états unis
au lendemain de ses funérailles
les tensions sont effectivement un peu
retomber car les magasins ont été pillés
il n'y a plus rien à voler et la police
a commencé à répéter à effectuer des
répressions sur le pillage tempe la
situation se calme
il ya encore des manifestations
pacifiques mais il n'ya plus de troubles
comme il y en avait auparavant parce que
la situation après deux semaines s'est
calmée mais je pense qu'il ya un
problème croissant dans différentes
régions qui pourraient resurgir lors des
élections c'est à dire vous pensez à
quelle région et pourquoi ça pourrait
resurgir lors des élections selon vous
deux ans à new york chicago et los
angeles les grandes régions libéral et
le problème c'est le démantèlement de la
police elle le fait qu'il souhaite un
coupé les vivres
car les gens essaient de profiter de ces
manifestations et ils essayent ils
essayent de mettre en avant cette idée
de supprimer la police
minneapolis par exemple est un très bon
exemple le conseil municipal a voté pour
mais coupé les financements de la police
je ne sais pas comment ça va se passer
c'est l'objectif suivant et cela va
poser de gros problèmes car il y aura
des élections bientôt à minneapolis et
dans d'autres lieux
donc s'il n'y a plus de police durera
beaucoup plus de violence quelle serait
pour vous la solution effectivement elle
semble assez radicale à minneapolis ce
démantèlement
quelle pourrait être la solution parce
que manifestement il ya un réel problème
avec la police aux etats-unis en tout
cas c'est ce qu'a corde à dire à peu
près tous les responsables politiques
sauf peut-être donald trump
en tout cas là il ya une vraie colère
aujourd'hui dans le pays il n'y a pas
des problèmes avec la police
certaines personnes perçoivent un
problème et certaines personne sont un
problème
elle suscite la colère elle encourage
les gens à pied a saccagé et à se
manifester
il n'y a pas de problème mais la
solution c'est de renforcer la police de
la rendre plus engagés et non pas de la
douce hier car si le problème c'est ce
qu'on veut faire c'est protéger les vies
des personnes noires alors il faut une
police plus forte et plus engagés et et
pas le contraire
enfin en l'occurrence c'est un policier
blanc qui a tué giorgio floyd jo bagdad
le premier candidat démocrate s'accorde
à dire voilà que désormais il faut une
justice raciale vous vous contestez ces
problèmes vous en tant que blogueur tout
simplement vous les aimiez vous pensez
qu'ils n'ont pas lieu ce n'est pas un
problème
joy byetone le dit qui arrive veut
devenir président et bien sûr c'est tout
le programme politique des démocrates
mais il n'y a pas de vraie issue de
vrais problèmes en 2010 m en 2009 seules
neuf personnes ont été tuées par la
police
et quand la plupart des cas c'était
justifié ces manifestations plutôt ces
émeutes ont causé 10 est peut-être même
20 morts de personnes noires je ne parle
pas des personnes qui sont mortes en
dehors de ces manifestations de ces
émeutes je ne parle que des blocs qui
sont liées directement une personne âgée
de 77 ans donc si l'on parle de
l'importance des vies noir alors il faut
se pencher sur ce problème
selon un sondage publié lundi par cnn
67% des américains considèrent désormais
que le racisme est un problème important
alors qu'ils n'étaient que 49 % en 2015
comment vous expliquer une telle
augmentation
les ump à tous il ya des facteurs tu ne
parles les médias insistent sur le sujet
oui
d'autre part des personnes qui écoutent
les médias qui les croient et qui
considère qu effectivement le racisme
doit être un problème car le médiatise
on leur dit que c'est un problème et le
croire et d'autres personnes sont plus
sceptiques se disent mais je ne constate
rien dans ma vie de tous les jours
autour de moi ou n'importe où je pense
que les médias insistent eux trouvent
sur ce sujet donc certaines personnes ne
suivent pas les médias et se font plutôt
sur leur expérience personnelle
si on nous regarde notre vie de tous les
jours il faut dire qu'effectivement le
racisme n'est pas vraiment un problème
merci anthony brian log le blogueur
politique d'avoir été avec nous et nous
avoir apporté votre opinion sur rt
france la vanille à présent huit coups
sur 10 viennent de madagascar la
campagne devait ni verte a démarré dans
le nord-ouest de l'île le marché dont la
réglementation encore été renforcée
cette année pour amener la qualité au
centre des préoccupations donne la
tendance sur les prix des gousses en
2020 après plusieurs années de flambée
des prix incontrôlée est la précieuse a
perdu de sa valeur à nab et dix ans sur
l'île de nosy komba deux tiers des
habitants cultivent la précieuse booth à
l'ombre d'une forêt tropicale
dans ce climat chaud et humide la
vanille est prête pour la récolte neuf
mois après la fécondation des fleurs par
la main de l'homme le boudebbouz doit
être jeune et on voit bien ici qui n'est
plus vert mais qu'il se rapproche plutôt
de la couleur de la banane
sandrine veine ans a planté ses
premières lianes de vanille alors que
les prix continuaient de grimper en 2017
il lui a fallu attendre deux ans pour
que les premières gouttes naissent en
il a pu vendre son premier sac de 9 kg
sur le marché sa récolte sera trois fois
plus importante cette année on fait très
attention
le produit est très cher les rumeurs
évalue le prix du kilo de vanille verte
cette année à 300 mille francs malgache
je ne sais pas si c'est vrai mais en
tout cas l'année dernière il se vendait
à un million de francs
les planteurs s'attendent à une baisse
drastique des prix avant même de quitter
la forêt pour le marché les acheteurs
des collecteurs revendeurs ou
exportateur affluent par bateau vers le
village dans diab et ce marché de
vanille et le plus important de tout
l'archipel de nocibé c'est dans le
nord-ouest du pays que les premières
gouttes malgaches sont récoltés chaque
année comme les autres
au moment où on parle les planteurs sont
encore à leur récolte des raisins est
tombé you we ils vont venir ici et le
marché dépend de sa les ventes ne
peuvent se faire pendant la nuit
donc si on voit que l'on ne peut pas
bouclé aujourd'hui on terminera demain
[Musique]
dès les premières ventes le ton est
donné
entre 15 et 20 euros le kilo pour la
gousse verte elle perd plus de 60% de sa
valeur par rapport à la précédente
campagne
quand on on voir les plis rehman
trois à quatre fois moins cher à qui il
ya des preuves années passées ça fait
mal
j'espère à quai l'année prochaine c'est
fini la couronne a vu tout ça là je
pense là les prix doit stable stabiliser
les prix
c'est l'effet recherché par une
réglementation renforcée cette année
pour éviter la spéculation
le vol des gousses et favoriser le
retour de la qualité l'état a mis en
place une série de décrets dates heures
et lieux des transactions sont encadrées
par les autorités locales sous étroite
surveillance des forces de l'ordre
le marché ne sera pas éternelle il y
avait un mix de ciron dit le marché
durera 2 jouent ces deux shows
rien que dans ce village de moins de
2000 habitants six tonnes de vanille
verte ont été vendues en deux jours la
filière qui compte deux cent mille
acteurs à madagascar produit vend et
exporte en moyenne 1700 tonnes de
vanille à travers le monde chaque année
avec 80% de la production mondiale
madagascar reste le leader incontesté
c'est ici que se dessinent les tendances
pour les prix à l'exportation à la
baisse cette année
le kilo de vanille noir devrait en
théorie lui aussi se vendre deux à trois
fois moins cher qu'en 2010 9,1 dans
quelques instants à rester avec nous
reviendrons en france en seine saint
denis neuf jeunes sur dix pensent que
les habitants sont discriminés par la
police ou la justice selon une enquête
réalisée par harris interactive pour le
conseil départemental puis nous
parlerons les
manifestation interdite en raison de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire mais parfois
toléré contre les violences policières
et le racisme
[Musique]
mais
oui
elle
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
ça fait maintenant plusieurs jeu direct
et c'est devenu presque que la france ou
financent sa recherche et son
enseignement supérieur à quoi est-ce que
vous attribuez ce manque de moyens c'est
un un problème politique au sens où ça
serait pas devant le projet politique
la grande cherche la place elle devrait
avoir parce que la recherche est un
élément central dans la prise en compte
et très très grand défi parce qu'elle
nous sommes et en particulier le défi
qui va être ses conséquences et
notamment une polémique là c'est la
première mais qui va y en avoir d'autres
il faut qu'ils aient pris de conscience
collective vraiment
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même on
vit tous les jours sans faire attention
que tout en dépend c'est l'unité de
mesure de toute chose une convention
admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
bertrand piccard vous vouliez prouvé que
l'on pouvait voyager au solaire et vous
avez fait le tour du monde
moi mon ambition c'est de montrer que
les technologies propres et les énergies
renouvelables peuvent faire des choses a
priori impossible sur l'apple c'était
vraiment le laboratoire volant qui
montrait que non seulement on pouvait
s'alimenter au solaire non plus on
pouvait être extrêmement efficients sur
le plan de l'énergie par rapport aux
problèmes là du climat de
l'environnement il ya un état d'urgence
actuellement est en état d'urgence
on est en train de détruire la
biodiversité s'accélère l'habitation ça
s'accélère de manière exponentielle ça
veut dire que chaque minute l'écart
entre ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on devrait
faire augmenter
oui donc c'est de plus en plus graves
[Musique]
l'histoire est plus compliquée que
certains veulent nous le faire croire
vouloir à la réécrire pour faire oublier
les échecs ne permet pas de comprendre
ce qui s'est vraiment passé
c'est ainsi que dans certains manuels de
cours d'histoire de nos enfants on veut
faire oublier napoléon bonaparte grand
organisateur de l'état moderne pour
profit de robespierre
le père de la terreur j'ai écouté le
président en train de pratiquer le déni
en oubliant carrément l'allier qui a eu
le triste privilège d'avoir le plus
grand nombre de morts dans la deuxième
guerre mondiale
mais si j'ai bien compris ils sont morts
pour rien puisque au nom d'une idéologie
on nie leur existence en oubliant une
partie de la game
l afrique et compte 1 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais nous
ne sommes pas encore au niveau où se
trouve par exemple l'europe ou les états
unis
quelle stratégie vous avez déployés dans
le sud kivu pour limiter la propagation
du virus on a proposé à ce qu'est le
confinement puisse être sélectif est
concerné seulement des personnes âgées à
haut risque de complication pour
sensibiliser la population
ça l'est beaucoup plus facilement
puisque on venait de sortir d'une d'une
épidémie d'ebola qui exige également la
distanciation social lavage des mains
qui était si on aura affaire à deux
épidémies aussi dangereuse qui est des
mollahs et coronavirus ça pourrait être
très très difficile pour nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les types de l'actualité de ce
mercredi 10 juin
c'est un sentiment qui prédomine celui
de la discrimination en
seine-saint-denis selon un sondage
harris interactive commandée par le
conseil départemental 56 % des habitants
disent avoir été discriminés au moins
une fois au cours des cinq dernières
années
les motifs sont dans l'ordre l'origine
de la couleur de la peau l'apparence
physique la religion ou bien encore le
quartier d'habitation la france devrait
en avoir fini avec l'état d'urgence
sanitaire le 10 juillet mais sa
disposition la plus sensible pourrait
elle être prolongé jusqu'en novembre un
projet de loi présenté aujourd'hui
donnerait toutefois la possibilité
edouard philippe de limiter ou
d'interdire les rassemblements sur la
voie publique ainsi que les réunions de
toutes natures une disposition loin de
faire l'unanimité alors que l'agenda
social est chargé ce sera l'objet de
notre face à face le vieux continent
retrouvent de la vigueur et poursuit son
déconfinement à la faveur du recul de
l'épidémie
l'union européenne pourrait ainsi
rouvrir partiellement ses frontières à
partir du 1er juillet prochain c'est ce
que propose aujourd'hui la commission
européenne avec une levée progressive
des restrictions se fondant sur une
approche commune
une sérieuse inquiétude celle du chef de
la diplomatie allemande en visite à
jérusalem quant aux projets israéliens
d'annexion de pente la cisjordanie
occupée faisant ainsi écho à celle de
l'union européenne le nouveau
gouvernement israélien du lion menée par
le premier ministre benyamin nétanyahou
et le ministre de la défense benny gantz
doit présenter le 1er juillet sa
stratégie pour traduire dans les faits
le plan de paix au proche-orient préparé
par l'administration entre eux
[Musique]
un tiers des habitants de la
seine-saint-denis déclare donc avoir
subi des discriminations ces cinq
dernières années en raison de leur
origine ou de leur couleur de peau selon
un sondage harris interactive sur le
département ont révélé aujourd'hui
ce sondage met également en lumière les
discriminations dans la police la
justice l'emploi ou encore le lange mans
voici quelques réactions à des habitants
du département
moi j'ai un français et un prénom
français donc sur le cv ça déclenche et
toujours l'entretien mais au moment de
l'entretien je voyais le petit bémol
dans le regard de la personne et là je
sentais un peu là la discrimination je
me sentais éliminé d'office mais ça n'a
jamais été très très direct donc on peut
jamais nommer ou date et un jour on a
été discriminée ça reste très difficile
m
on le sait on sait qu'elle est là la
discrimination au travail à l'école même
dans la rue mais déjà arrivé de vivre
des situations discriminantes c'est
comme ça faut juste nous ça nous nous
adapter de fer avec deux mâts de se
battre deux fois plus que des personnes
non racisées en fait mais ça changera
pas faut pas rêver je pense pas
effectivement j'ai déjà eu des problèmes
dont je suis allé voir la police et on
m'a tenu enfin on me croyait pas et
justement on m'a dit on fait ce que ben
pour nous clairement en fait tu vas voir
toute cette histoire pour avoir le
papier français alors moi je pense que
c'est vrai que quand on est jeune dans
le 93 et qu on a une ethnie qui vient
du sud quoi d'afrique ben on a plus de
chances d'être contrôlé ça c'est sûr à
200 % après moi j'ai des amis blancs qui
eux mêmes reconnaissent qu'ils ont vu
que certains privilèges de ne pas se
faire contrôler quelques fois par les
policiers parce que justement ils ont ce
privilège d'être blanc et pour farid
thème c'est mamie n'y porte parole de
l'association banlieues plus ces
discriminations ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui
maintenant ça fait plusieurs générations
ça fait plus de 40 ans maintenant que
les difficultés subsistent le
département concentre l'ensemble des
idées et des fléaux que l'on peut
trouver dans d'autres deals dans
d'autres pays dans d'autres départements
pardonnez moi et donc du coup lorsque la
crise et puissante comme celle que nous
vivons aujourd'hui est bien le ressenti
est encore plus important et lorsque
vous y rajoutez une émotion mondiale
avec ce qui s'est passé aux états unis
vous avez un ressentiment qui encore
plus exacerbée et en tout cas c'est une
réalité
maintenant il faut savoir la traiter ça
n'a pas été chose facile ou en tout cas
ça n'est pas du tout une réussite si on
prend ce département là depuis
maintenant une quarantaine d'années je
pense qu'il faut complètement changé les
outils pour lutter contre ces maux de
notre société
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire naturellement
alors ça ça peut pas être réglé d'un
coup de baguette magique mais c'est une
question de volonté politique et de
moyens mise à disposition or malgré les
effets d'annoncé ici ou là la réalité
c'est que les moyens ne sont pas à la
hauteur des défis de notre départ du
département de la seine saint denis et
plus on va plus on avance et plus on
fait ces difficultés vont se creuser et
c'est pour ça que je suis très alarmiste
concernant ce département là et pour en
parler nous sommes avec michel kokoreff
professeur de sociologie à paris 8
saint-denis bonsoir michel
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
ce sondage qui on l'imaginé bien je vais
vous laisser répondent évidemment mais
ne vous étonne peut-être pas ce que
c'est cette affaire giorgio floyd outre
atlantique était en train de réveiller
les consciences alors on peut penser que
ça réveille les médias en tout cas parce
qu'effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
existe depuis depuis vingt ans les
discriminations c'est à dire les la mise
à l'écart pour l'origine pour la couleur
de peau ou pour d'autres
caractéristiques
c'est devenu la grande affaire depuis
une vingtaine d'années il ya une enquête
qui était très intéressante qui avait
été publiée par l'ined l'institut
national des études démographiques en
2008 et qui montrait que notamment sur
le département de seine-saint-denis
il y avait à peu près 25% de natifs
c'est-à-dire de français nés de parents
français donc qui habitait en seine
saint denis
donc le reste 75 % de d'immigrés de
descendants d'immigrés de deux personnes
originaires des dom-tom bon et
effectivement dans cette dans ce
contexte là urbain avec donc 25 % de
français français disons les
discriminations étaient était très très
majoritaire est surtout perçue de façon
très aigu par par cette population donc
que c'est immonde et on découvre là ce
qui vient d'être dit par le représentant
de france plus de banlieue plus on
découvre là quelque chose qui est assez
ancien et très enracinée et qui semble
selon ce sondage augmenté depuis ces
cinq dernières années 42% en tout cas
des personnes pensent que ces phénomènes
ont augmenté contre donc c'est des cinq
dernières années qu'est ce qui se serait
passé parce qu'on a tendance peut-être à
croire que plus on avance plus on va
vers l'assimilation peut-être et ça ne
semble pas être le cas
oui alors moi ce qui me semble quand
même assez frappant c'est l'extension du
domaine
des discriminations c'est à dire que
bora répondre à votre question aux
précédentes sans doute la sphère de la
mort horrible de georges floyd alimente
ce phénomène mais on voit bien que au
delà des rapports compliqués avec la
police ce qu'on appelle le contrôle au
faciès les discriminations quotidiennes
que subissent les jeunes il ya d'autres
domaines il ya l'emploi il ya logement
il ya la justice il ya l'accès aux
services et aux loisirs les fameuses
discothèque
donc on a l'impression qu'il n'ya pas un
domaine de la vie sociale ou la
population en général les plus jeunes
comme les plus vieux mais en particulier
les plus jeunes ne n'est pas confronté à
cette cette mise à l'écart et à ce qu'il
faut bien appeler des discriminations
ethniques et raciales principalement
alors comment vous l'expliquez vous
savez dire quoi concrètement
il ya clairement du racisme il ya de
l'incompréhension il ya des différences
de cultures qui font que les choses sont
parfois compliquées quelle est votre
analyse
l'analyse alors dans le cas de la seine
saint denis si puisque c'est la base de
ceux de ce sondage c'est je le rappelle
on est face à un processus de
ghettoïsation
c'est à dire avec majoritairement une
population qui est d'origine de
descendance étrangère plus ou moins plus
ou moins récentes
donc je pense que la base du problème il
est là il est dans la concentration
ethnique de population qui par ailleurs
sont largement issus de milieux
populaires qui sont donc confrontés plus
que les autres populations dites
blanches ou non racisées au chômage et
donc effectivement
on rejoint aussi un processus qui est
ancien qui s'appelle le racisme
structurel le racisme systémique et qui
permet de faire des liens avec les états
unis même si la france n'est pas les
états unis l'a bien un processus
enraciné bomba qui fait que pour
embaucher quelqu'un quand il a un nom de
consonance maghrébine dans se demande si
au fond il sera capable
il est aussi compétent ou ici sera pas
un peu intégristes pour redire peut-être
des choses choquantes mais qui
corresponde à une réalité
je reviens à ma précédente question
laquelle vous n'avez pas répondu
qu'est ce qui s'est passé les cinq
dernières années parce que ce phénomène
tend à s'amplifier alors qu'on pourrait
imaginer que on va vers le progrès ça
empire pourquoi selon vous écoutez si
les choses empirent c'est pas depuis
cinq ans et pas non plus depuis
l'élection d' emmanuel macron voilà
alors une pièce à 31 sur et qui pour moi
n'est qu'un n'est qu'un sondage donc
qu'il faut prendre avec avec beaucoup de
précaution mais il me semble que ce que
disent les gens que vous avez interviewé
et des gens que j'ai pu rencontrer lors
de mes deux mains enquête c'est que
effectivement c'est un processus qui
date de 40 ans bon c'est un processus
long c'est pas quelque chose qui qui
date d'aujourd'hui
donc depuis cinq ans je vois pas
éventuellement on pourrait prendre comme
repère la crise de subprimes en 2007
oh il ya eu un effet évident sur les
populations qui habitent dans les zones
urbaines sensibles
alors que les populations qui vivaient
en dehors de ces zones urbaines
sensibles étaient peu ou pas touchés par
le chômage ou une limitation de
de l'activité donc si vous laissez un
peu difficile sur la base d'un sondage
de dire eh bien depuis cinq ans voilà ce
qui s'est passé qui qui expliquerait
cette évolution
il faudra avoir les prochaines années si
ce sondage est refait dans deux donc de
façon un peu dans la continuité là on
sera peut-être plus en mesure de saisir
des détournant ou d où des différences
mais je pense qu'il ya un vrai problème
structurel en france liées aux
discriminations ethniques et raciales
que le président du département de
seine-saint-denis ne nomme pas en tant
que tel donc ça montre que il appelle à
faire un plan contre les discriminations
mais quelle discrimination
moi je dis ethniques et raciales et donc
d'une certaine manière il ya une sorte
de déni et peut-être que la faire et ce
qui se passe aux etats-unis actuellement
autour de la de la mort de georges floyd
et à un effet révélateur
et de ce point de vue là que les choses
soient prises en main notamment par les
politiques ou les forces vives la
société civile c'est plutôt une bonne
chose et de sortir de la visibilité de
sortir de quelque chose voilà qui se
seraient cachés et qui serait connue des
seuls habitants merci beaucoup
michel kokoreff d'avoir été avec mon
direct sur rt france merci la france
devrait en avoir fini avec l'état
d'urgence sanitaire le 10 juillet mais
sa disposition la plus sensible pourrait
elle être prolongé jusqu'en novembre à
projets de loi présentés aujourd'hui
donnerait la possibilité à edouard
philippe de limiter ou d'interdire les
rassemblements sur la voie publique
alors que les réunions de toutes natures
sauf que certains y voient aussi un
prétexte pour interdire les
manifestations à venir
un ensemble d'organisations la cgt au
syndicat des avocats de france appelle
au respect du droit aux mêmes d'un
manifesté et précisément les
manifestations dépit de l'interdiction
des rassemblements de plus de 10
personnes se sont multipliés ces
derniers jours dans le sillage de les
faire floyd aux etats-unis le personnel
soignant lui en france appelle à
plusieurs journées de mobilisation alors
question y at il un deux poids deux
mesures dans le traitement des
manifestations dont certaines sont
tolérés d'autres noms c'est l'objet de
notre face à face ce soit et pour en
débattre nous sommes en direct avec atom
apporte à dirigeant national du pcf en
charge du collectif des cheminots auteur
de au coeur de laine aux éditions
arcane17 bonsoir thomas porte merci
d'être avec nous pour en débattre avec
vous julien ondulent conseiller régional
rassemblement national bonsoir à vous
également julien odoul alors il n'y aura
pas de sanction contre les participants
les manifestations sont interdites mais
tolérée c'était les mots de christophe
castaner hier à quelques heures
justement avant ces rassemblements en
mémoire à giorgio foid contre les
violences policières et contre le
racisme
julien aux boules quelle a été votre
réaction à cette tolérance entre nîmes
et du ministre de l'intérieur
j'ai été scandalisé par cette annonce de
christophe castaner puisque je me
rappelle qu'il ya 18 mois les
manifestations des gilet jaune et t elle
même durement réprimé avec une brutalité
politiques extrêmes
elle n'était pas elle était interdite et
elles étaient réprimées là nous avons
des manifestations dont on nous dit
qu'elles sont interdites mais qu'elles
sont finalement toléré et qu'elles sont
tolérés sous le prétexte totalement
délirant que c'est l'émotion au mondial
que c'est la mort de georges floyd et
donc ça autorise tout et ça permet
finalement de bafouer l'état de droit ça
permet de passer outre les consignes
sanitaires je rappelle quand même que
nous venons de traverser une crise
sanitaire sans précédent que nous avons
près de 30000 morts dans notre pays que
nous ne sommes pas encore sortis et que
ces consignes sont extrêmement
importante donc l'émotion moi j'aurais
aimé qu'elle soit aussi pour les gilet
jaune puisque les gilets jaunes c'était
aussi l'émotion de gens qui venaient
crier leur ras-le-bol face à un
matraquage fiscal face à des conditions
de vie abominable face à un état qui ne
les écoute pas face à des personnes
aujourd'hui dans notre pays qui ne
peuvent pas se soigner qui ne mangent
pas à leur faim
moi j'aurais aimé aussi qu'on écoute
cette émotion là on constate que le
gouvernement ait eu de macron finalement
c'est de la discrimination
discrimination à l'égard des classes
populaires à l'égard des manifestants
défilent et jaune
mais pour ce qui est des mutants
racialiste pour ce qui est des partisans
de monsieur adama sall ya aucun problème
les manifestations seront tolérés c'est
un véritable scandale qui en dit long
sur l'abaissement de l'état de notre
pays s'en va par quatre avec soin je
crois que moi je suis pas là pour
reposer les mobilisations
j'ai été aussi le premier à dénoncer les
violences policières dont ont été
victimes les gie les jeunes croient que
le pouvoir que la bonne décision en
tolérant ces mobilisations j'espère
qu'il va faire de même avec les
soignants et aujourd'hui c'est
absolument pas des mobilisations assia
liste cd mobilisation qui inscrivent
dans une exigence de justice et de
transparence
elles répondent aux mêmes idéaux que
toutes les mobilisations sociales qui
est dans le pays depuis des semaines
c'est à dire plus de services publics
plus d'égalité et aujourd'hui c'est ça
ce qu'on dénonce ce que dénonce et
mobilisation c'est une police qui
aujourd'hui se permet d'avoir une
violence extrêmement importante à la
fois les gardes et gilet jaune mais
aussi dans les quartiers populaires les
chiffres le disent il ya un dernier
sondage qui a été dans le chic temps de
pause qui dit qu' un tiers des français
se sent aujourd'hui en ag face à la
police donc il faudra répondre à ces
questions là et le gouvernement n'y
réponds pas aujourd'hui et les
mobilisations elles vont continuer tant
que vous pouvez en émoi mais là vous
vous répondez sur le fond démobilisation
mais c'est bien tout l'objet de ce débat
est ce que christophe castaner à raison
justement d'opposer
les raisons ces mobilisations est-ce que
c'est plus important voilà d'aller
manifester pour le contre le racisme que
comptent les voilà les problèmes à
l'hôpital où c'est ça le sujet de fond
finalement est ce que un ministre a
raison de tolérer au nom de l'émotion
ces rassemblements alors qu'on le
rappelle tout de même que les
rassemblements sont interdits de plus de
10 personnes aujourd'hui dans le pays 1
on empêche par exemple des familles
d'enterrer leurs proches correctement
c'est ça le sujet aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui de classification à faire
sur les mobilisations qu'elle soit
contre les violences policières contre
le climat ou pour un service click de la
santé elles sont toutes légitimes elles
ont toutes des revendications de
concrètes qui doivent permettre de
s'exprimer maintenant je vois que
monsieur odoul s'insurge sur le fait que
les gilets jaunes ont été réprimées je
n'ai pas entendu monté au créneau quand
le 1er mai 2019 la cgt a été violentée
par les forces de l'ordre et on a dû à
exfiltrer le secrétaire général de la
cgt philippe martinez donc voilà il ya
aussi un deux poids deux mesures moi je
considère que la répression policière
des manifestations ne doit jamais
s'exercer dans le cadre de mobilisations
sociales qui sont pacifiques
on le voit les mobilisations contre les
violences policières en memory of love
elle se passe très bien il n'y a pas de
débordements et c'est une religion si
elles sont pacifiques et la question de
la langue employée des slogans quand
vous voyez les pancartes mort au port
comme vous voyez qu on entonne des
chants appelant à prendre les armes
contre nos policiers c'est tout sauf
pacifique
vous appelez à la haine de la france
vous appeler à la haine de nos policiers
vous appeler à la guerre raciale
c'est tout ce que je ne veux pas pour
mon pays parce que moi contrairement à
vous monsieur porte mon pays je ne le
vois pas en fonction de couleurs si ce
n'est trois le bleu le blanc et le rouge
moi je ne vois pas les individus en
fonction de leur origine moi je vois des
français et citoyen français et la
guerre raciale qui donc que nous ne
voulons pas que ces racialiste je dirais
appellent de leurs voeux par ces
manifestations en essayant de cliver en
essayant de renvoyer un policier donc
dans le rang des vendus c'est totalement
un d'une part ses tâtonnements
innommable et d'autre part c'est
dangereux c'est dangereux pour la france
dans laquelle nous voulons vivre demain
donc il faut y mettre un terme moi ce
que j'entends et ce que je vois cela n'a
rien de pacifique
ce serait bien que le ministre de
l'intérieur que le gouvernement dise une
bonne fois pour toutes stop
ces manifestations elles sont interdites
elles sont interdites d'une part parce
qu'est l'état d'urgence sanitaire et
d'autre part parce qu'elles appellent à
la haine raciale
je crois qu'elle n'appelle pas du tout à
la haine raciale et vous vous ne
trouverez pas là pour défendre les
slogans qui sans en prononcer elle porte
une exigence celle de la transparence
sur la question des violences policières
et vous voulez l'évacuer et tous les
chiffres le disent
l'augmentation dès violences policières
et là on a aujourd'hui une police qui a
tué des personnes et adama traoré année
1k et d'ailleurs vous avez dit aux gens
si vous avez dit vous avez dit hier que
adama 3 y avaient été tués parce que
c'était un délinquant et que rien n'est
imposé le fait qu'il ne reste plus donc
monsieur odoul quand vous avez été mis
en examen pour recel de détournement
d'argent public
la police n'est pas venu chez vous elle
n'est pas venue vous agressez monsieur
croc monsieur temps du fait des
amalgames qui sont préparés à y remonter
ça n'a rien à voir je sais que ces deux
devises inra habituel mais un moment
donné il faut revoir qu'est ce que la
normalité dans notre pays qu'est ce que
nous voulons pour notre société
est ce que nous voulons une société de
paix et de sécurité la paix et la
sécurité malheureusement dans toute
société humaine
elle est garantie par la violence
légitime exercée par les forces de
l'ordre par la police républicaine et la
police républicaine rempli sa mission
je dirais en france la police qu'on me
républicaine rempli sa mission avec
professionnalisme avec le souci des
personnes la sécurité des personnes avec
le souci du respect de la loi
ça c'est la police française et c'est
pas les caricatures qu'on entente
alors évidemment que comme dans tous les
corps de la société comme dans tous les
métiers il peut y avoir des brebis
galeuses il peut y avoir un individu qui
pète déploré peut y avoir des individus
qui sont moins bien formés
mais jeter le discrédit de cette façon
sur toute une institution qui est
essentiel pour notre vivre en paix en
france alors je trouve ça magique
toujours voulez vous faire réagir sur
cette autre déclaration de christophe
castaner qui a beaucoup fait parler de
lui
manifestement ces derniers jours le
ministre de l'intérieur qui était
l'invité d'une mattila l'info d'une
grande chaîne interrogée sur
l'interdiction de la manif des soignants
prévue mardi prochain à cause des règles
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire voici sa
réponse il faut que les manifestations
soit déclaré il est important aussi de
rappeler le droit mais surtout les
conditions sanitaires
les personnels soignants le savent mieux
que d'autres
une manifestation aujourd'hui c'est
prendre le risque de diffuser le virus
thomas porte ça vous inspire quoi ça
c'est dangereux de manifester avant
c'était dangereux à cause des black
blocs là c'est le virus est ce que selon
vous voilà il ya eu une arrière pensée
de la part du gouvernement qui voudrait
décourager les gens à manifester dans ce
pays aujourd'hui
évidemment qu'une tentative de mettre
fin aux mobilisations sociales quelle
qu'elle soit on a connu la répression
avant le gorna virus et on sait qu'on
aura une répression après jusque tout ce
qui tend à remettre en cause aujourd'hui
le maquereau nisme va être montré du
doigt par ce projet et le secteur de la
santé peut être celui qui coagule les
colères populaires parce qu'on a bien
compris dans ce pays qu'on avait besoin
d'un grand cerf l'esprit de la santé qui
permettent à tout et tout de se soigner
correctement et cette crise n a mis en
avant les décisions politiques qui ont
été pris depuis des années qui ont
détruit ce service public et la majorité
la très grande majorité des gens ont
compris qu'il fallait sortir des
logiques de rentabilité qu'un hôpital
n'est pas un tableur excel est
aujourd'hui s'il ya bien un secteur qui
en pointe qui était en lutte depuis un
an que le gouvernement n'avait pas
écouté les soignants et t-mobile de
violence qui était énorme
il ne les a pas écoutés il les a
applaudis et aujourd'hui veulent leur
interdire un nouveau de manifester leur
colère
je crois que c'est pas très sérieux mais
christophe castaner est tout sauf un
ministre de l'intérieur puisque les
décisions sont d'une incohérence totale
les prises de position répondent aux
intérêts du jour il n'y a pas de ligne
de conduite
moi j'espère vraiment que les soignants
vont être nombreux à se mobiliser
j'espère aussi que la population qui les
a applaudi pendant des semaines et des
mois va être à leurs côtés pour exiger
aujourd'hui d'avoir un service public
hospitalier de digne avec des conditions
de travail décentes et une hausse des
salaires qui permettent à toutes et tous
de se soigner dans ce pays et julien
houle donc manifestation soignant est
prévue demain comme tous les jeudis une
grosse le 16 juin est ce qu'on doit
l'autoriser puisque on nous prévient que
ça va être quand même dangereux oui je
suis tout à fait en accord une fois
n'est pas coutume avec ce que je viens
de dire thomas porte notamment sur le
sauvetage de l'hôpital public et notre
système de santé
ce qui est hallucinant dans les propos
de christophe castaner c'est
véritablement ce deux poids deux mesures
pourquoi les personnels soignants
donc seraient plus susceptibles de
propager le virus et non pas les
militants racialiste pourquoi ceux qui
veulent sauver l'hôpital public donc
devrait s'astreindre aux règles
sanitaires et non pas ceux qui défilent
pour georges floyd un moment donné la
règle la loi et doit être la même pour
tous sinon il ya du vrai public
sinon il ya plus de démocratie je dirais
sinon c'est l'anarchie et tout ça ne
nous ne pouvons pas l'accepter
donc oui j'espère que les personnels
soignants vont se mobiliser nombreux
parce que leur combat est légitime parce
que ça fait des années qu'ils tirent la
sonnette d'alarmé parce que nous avons
un système de santé qui sait tiers-monde
is et qui a été je dirais mis en coupe
réglée par ce gouvernement dont qui ne
voit que la rentabilité à outrance et
qui n'a pas tiré visiblement les leçons
de ces semaines de crise donc oui
j'espère qu'ils vont se mobiliser
et oui j'espère aussi que le ministre de
l'intérieur va arrêter de faire sont
deux poids deux mesure où ces
discriminations et une bonne fois pour
toutes
arrêtez d'être le ministre du désordre
les désordres et de la confrontation à
un moment donné ça suffit
notre pays on a trop souffert donc la
règle la loi doit être la même pour tous
en france
merci je n'ai redoublent merci également
à vous auto m'apporte d'avoir été en
direct avec nous sur rt france pour ce
débat restez avec nous dans quelques
instants nous reviendrons sur
l'ouverture partielle des frontières de
l'union européenne au 1er juillet prenez
par la commission européenne
elle va publier dans une semaine ces
propositions et puis direction jérusalem
où le chef de la diplomatie allemande a
fait part de l' sérieuses inquiétudes de
son pays quand on projet israélien
d'annexion dépend de la cisjordanie
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
nous permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et d'un fonds karl de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
cata c'est trop fine il ya un tournant
mais on recevait à vivre mais dans une
autre direction
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines la moitié de la
planète
jamais on a fait ça jamais là d'une
décision invraisemblable pour vous ça
dépend telles valeurs on attribue à la
mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie revient
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas c'est un débat n'aura
un débat éthique
[Musique]
comme d'habitude on rajoute de la bête
parce qu'on aime ça
on aime beaucoup la bête pour la
première fois on parle une tête commune
à messieurs c'est tout à fait nouveau
est-ce que vous pensez que vous avez des
gens qui dans le pays bas en france vont
vouloir les payer des impôts pour les
grecs pour les italiens alors monsieur
votre place à l'italie et à l'espagne
sont elles les principaux bénéficiaires
c'est un message fort selon vous envoyez
à ces pays riches qui se joue dans cette
histoire c'est la marche marot de tous
les pays où toute l'europe l'europe est
morte
enfin a ajouté qu'elle est morte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l afrique et compte 1 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais nous
ne sommes pas encore au niveau où se
trouve par exemple l'europe ou les états
unis
quelle stratégie vous avez déployés dans
le sud kivu pour limiter la propagation
du virus on a proposé à ce qu'est le
confinement puisse être sélectif est
concerné seulement des personnes âgées à
haut risque de complication pour
sensibiliser la population
ça l'est beaucoup plus facilement
puisque on venait de sortir d'une d'une
épidémie d'ebola qui exige également la
distanciation social lavage des mains
qui aidera si on aura affaire à deux
épidémies aussi dangereuse qui est beau
la et coronavirus ça pourrait être très
très difficile pour nous
[Musique]
bonsoir merci nous rejoindre en direct
sur rt france 21h30 heure française
avec le recul de l'épidémie de kobe 19
ans l'europe le déconfinement se
poursuit
l'union européenne pourrait rouvrir
partiellement ses frontières à partir du
1er juillet prochain
c'est ce que propose en tout cas la
commission européenne aujourd'hui il
s'agirait de lever progressivement les
restrictions avec certains pays tiers
ont fait le point avec les îles à saraf
le déconfinement se poursuit en europe
alors que les nouvelles hospitalisations
les chiffres des décès liés aux
coronavirus sont en chute libre sur le
continent la réouverture des frontières
avec les autres pays hors union
européenne pourrait avoir lieu dès le
mois prochain
la levée des restrictions temporaires de
voyage aux frontières extérieures
interviendra dans un deuxième temps est
à cet égard le collège des commissaires
européens adoptera dans le courant de la
semaine son évaluation des restrictions
de voyage
il proposera une approche pour la levée
progressive et partielle de ces
restrictions
à partir du 1er juillet avec certains
pays tiers en tenant compte d'un certain
nombre de principes et de critères sur
la base d'une approche commune
coordonnée des états membres est
soutenue par la commission l'exécutif
européen ne peut émettre qu'un avis la
décision finale appartient à chaque état
membre
l'allemagne a décidé de jouer la carte
de la prudence en prolongeant jusqu'au
31 août ses mises en garde sur les
voyages en dehors de l'union européenne
la liberté de circulation sera à nouveau
établi au sein de l'europe et l'union
européenne pour être précis
une décision prise en fonction de la
situation due à la pandémie
[Musique]
et si contrairement aux attentes cette
situation devait se détériorer
nous avons convenu que nous pourrons
reconsidérer des choses à tout moment de
son côté l'autriche a établi une liste
de 31 pays avec lesquels la liberté de
voyage va être établi le 16 juin la
suède l'espagne le portugal et le
royaume-uni en sont exclus
l'assouplissement des restrictions et
donc à l'ordre du jour partout dans le
monde
plusieurs dirigeants européens dont le
président français emmanuel macron et la
chancelière allemande angela merkel ont
néanmoins demandé cette semaine a lieu
que soit étudié les moyens de mieux se
préparer à la prochaine pandémie
estimant qu'elle n'avait pas été à la
hauteur à propos du coc vite 19 et pour
en parler nous sommes avec françois
poule et matiz journaliste spécialiste
de l'europe bonsoir en soit vous les
mathis merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france une levée progressive et
partielle en tout cas c'est ce que
souhaite la commission européenne à
partir du 1er juillet
bonne idée selon vous je crois qu'il
s'agit tout simplement d'essayer de
sauver au moins la saison touristique
faut pas oublier quand même qu'une bonne
partie de l'europe toute l'europe du sud
en particulier est très affecté par
cette crise est particulièrement s'il
fallait envisager une fermeture des
frontières qui va au delà de la date
actuelle c'est-à-dire qui couvre les
vacances il s'agit donc essentiellement
d'essayer de sauver le tourisme des
civils sauver les vacances qui sont une
source nécessaire est absolument
indispensable pour relancer l'économie
donc je crois que c'est une bonne idée
d'autant plus que tous les chiffres
montrent bon dans le même sens d'une
baisse du virus en europe
par contre la vigilance s'impose puisque
on le voit très bien en amérique le
coeur du virus est encore très actifs et
donc la d7 prudence est nécessaire mais
je crois qu'il faut considérer deux
périodes
il ya la période d'avant et pendant qu
vide 19
c'est à dire la crise pendant laquelle
l'europe il faut bien de l'avouer a été
fondamentalement absente elle a été
fondamentalement impuissante et c'est
bien de ça dont il s'agit de rattraper
aujourd'hui pourquoi la commission
européenne at-elle aujourd'hui pris les
devants pour essayer de proposer une
date
tout simplement parce qu'elle a
conscience qu'elle a été trop absente et
qu'il fallait maintenant qu'elle
reprenne un peu les rênes
alors vous l'avez dit dans le reportage
la commission n'est pas compétente pour
fixer une date d'ouverture des
frontières mais elle est compétente pour
essayer de donner avec autorité un
conseil qui lui devrait permettre
effectivement des rouvrir les frontières
au moins à partir du 1er juillet et en
respectant toutes les mesures
nécessaires alors le vice président
josep borrell parle effectivement d'
approche commune entre états membres je
vous l'avais bien expliqué il faut
essayer de fédérer tout ça ce qui a
manqué cruellement
ces dernières semaines est ce que ça
vous semble possible aujourd'hui avec le
spectacle qu'on nous a montré quand même
ces derniers mois alors je tirais c'est
assez possible pour une raison bien
simple parce que les pays européens ont
agi seul d'une certaine manière en
décidant eux mêmes les mesures qu'ils
allaient prendre pour lutter contre ce
virus sur leur territoire
mais ils sont confrontés à la
perspective de demain et demain
malheureusement les états pris
individuellement vont être très désarmés
pour essayer de faire face à la crise
économique énorme épouvantable qui était
en train de se profiler
c'est pour faire face à cette crise
économique qui s'annonce
il n'y a pas 36 solutions les pays n'ont
pas de solution on le voit très bien
seul l'ensemble des pays européens qui
se coordonnent pouvoir trouver des
solutions pour financer en particulier
la banque centrale européenne n'a déjà
fait en dégageant un certain nombre de
milliards d'euros pour essayer de
débloquer les économies mais cela va
être nécessaire de continuer c'est sur
cette démarche
alors comment continuer et bien tout
simplement en confirmant au niveau des
27 et non plus seul
chaque pays pris séparément la nécessité
de mettre en commun des actions qui
doivent permettre effectivement d'une
part de faire face éventuellement à un
rebond du virus
et pour ça il faudra effectivement
éviter de reproduire les erreurs qu'on a
connus au début et puis d'autre part
pour préparer la suite c'est-à-dire
d'aider les économies de l'union
européenne d'aider à se redresser et ça
elles ont bien besoin
et oui alors certaines plus que d'autres
un certain pays en plus souffert que
d'autres
comment faire avaler justement la pilule
c'est l'éternel débat avec l'europe de
ce finalement qui ont peut-être mieux
gérer et donc moins son fer on a eu
quand même petite initiative qui n'est
pas négligeable qui est celle qui a été
prise par le président français emmanuel
macron avec angela merkel qui est
d'accepter pour la première fois pour
les allemands c'est vraiment une
première d'accepter une certaine forme
de mutualisation des dettes alors non
pas des dettes existantes mais de
mutualiser les dettes à venir en les
dettes à venir elles vont être
considérables ça veut dire que pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'europe des pays qui sont relativement
riches vont pouvoir accepter de
mutualiser un petit peu l'effort
budgétaire avec des pays qui eux ont
subi de plein fouet la crise et donc ça
c'est véritablement une première c'est
une première marque qui montre que
l'europe est capable
finalement lorsqu'elle est mis au pied
du mur
de trouver des solutions concrètes pour
essayer d'en sortir
l'italie s'était fortement place au
début de la crise du coup quand un virus
vous en souvenez de voir ce manque de
solidarité évidente de la part des
autres pays européens
aujourd'hui elle constate que l'ensemble
des pays européens de d'un certain
commun accord sont accepte finalement de
faire un travail en commun c'est pas
encore gagné parce que l'effort de
mutualisation de la dette il faut encore
obtenir l'accord des 27 qui n'est pas
encore totalement obtenu mais on est sur
une bonne voie d'autant plus qu' à la
couverture qui est importante de la
banque centrale européenne qui n accepte
aujourd'hui de d'acheter de la dette et
acheter de la dette d'une certaine
manière c'est en partie finalement la
supprimer en partie seulement alors
réparer les dégâts l'europe va s'y
atteler donc préparer l'avenir aussi
vous l'aviez évoqué rapidement un gala
mais recalé emmanuel macron qui est dans
une lettre rappelait justement l'europe
à préparer une éventuelle nouvelle
pandémie ça veut dire quoi il faut
revoir vraiment où cette fois-ci agir
d'un front commun au niveau européen et
plus état par état
il ya des erreurs qui ne faut pas en
reconnaître de nouveaux par exemple
celle de constater que dans certains
pays on manque cruellement de masques ou
alors des équipements d'urgence de
réanimateurs et c'est donc la
proposition de l'homme qui semble tout à
fait naturel c'est de faire en sorte de
ensemble constitué un stock par exemple
prévient première initiative constitue
un stock considérable de masques de
matériel de réanimation de matériels
médicaux et surtout de médicaments
éviter d'être sous la tutelle d'autres
pays et notamment pays asiatiques en ce
qui concerne la fabrication de
médicaments
ça c'est une urgence absolue et ça il
semble que là dessus
l'ensemble des pays soient d'accord pour
dire bombay il faut y aller et ça c'est
au niveau européen c'est pas au niveau
national qu il faudra le faire et puis à
la deuxième
la deuxième étape ce sera effectivement
de se mettre en commun pour la remise en
route des économies c'est de faire en
sorte que l'ouverture des frontières ne
servent pas à faire communiquer une
virus b servent à communiquer des
marchandises ces règles affaires
communiqué
retrait des économies pour que les
économies des différents pays des 27
pays de l'union européenne puisse
véritablement redémarré
parce qu'ils sont en très mauvaise
posture en ce moment merci beaucoup
françois pour les métis journaliste
spécialiste de l'europe d'avoir été avec
nous nous avoir apporté votre analyse
la mise en garde du ministre allemand
des affaires étrangères à israël en
visite à jérusalem heiko maas a prévenu
les arbres son projet d'annexion et
d'une partie de la cisr jany violerait
le droit international un avertissement
alors que l'allemagne prendra la
présidence tournante du conseil de
l'union européenne le 1er juillet
prochain
de son côté le chef de la diplomatie
israélienne appelle bruxelles nal pas à
ne pas prendre de décision trop rapide
nous pensons comme l'union européenne
que l'annexion est incompatible avec le
droit international
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
soutenons toujours une solution négociée
et consensuelle à deux états il est
important pour nous d'entendre la
position de l'allemagne
l'allemagne est notre ami et je suppose
qu'elle attendra d'abord une décision
israélienne concernant l'annexion et
qu'elle prendra ensuite la sienne je
peux nous attendons qu'il en soit ainsi
et qu'aucune mesure s'il doit rien à
voir ne soit prise avant la décision
israélienne le 1er juillet prochain
c'est aussi la dette avec elles le
nouveau gouvernement israélien d'union
emmenée par le premier ministre
netanyahu doit présenter dans sa
stratégie pour traduire dans les faits
le plan de paix au proche-orient préparé
par l'administration trump un plan
saluer côté israélien comme une
opportunité historique françois xavier
lambert
ce sera la première grande annonce du
nouveau gouvernement d'union israéliens
les modalités d'application concrète du
plan de paix américain pour le proche
orient
présenté en janvier dernier à washington
ce projet va plus loin que tous les
précédents
il propose notamment une solution à deux
états mais octroie à israël l'annexion
de ces colonies en cisjordanie ainsi que
l'annexion de la vallée du jourdain
présent aux côtés de donald trump
benyamin nétanyahou avait salué un jour
historique dans l'histoire de son pays
monsieur le président je pense qu'au
cours des prochaines décennies et
peut-être au cours des prochains siècles
nous nous souviendrons également du 28
janvier 2020
car ce jour là vous êtes devenu le
premier leader mondial à reconnaître la
souveraineté d'israël sur des zones
comme la judée samarie qui sont vitales
pour notre sécurité et qui sont au coeur
de notre patrimoine se clôt américain a
d'emblée été rejetées par les
palestiniens
pour l'autorité palestinienne sont
d'application mettrait fin au processus
de paix avec israël
celle ci a donc présenté son propre
projet prévoyant la création d'un état
indépendant est démilitarisé
les frontières avec israël ne serait que
partiellement modifié par rapport à
celle gelé en 1967 pour le premier
ministre palestinien
la communauté internationale doit
pousser l'état hébreu à renoncer à ses
projets d'annexion cisjordanie ce que
nous espérons c'est qu'israël ne s'en
tirent pas comme ça ce que nous espérons
c'est qu'israël ne continue pas à se
placer au dessus de la loi
internationale
nous souhaitons qu'israël ressentent la
pression internationale les palestiniens
semblent avoir été entendus par l'union
européenne
bruxelles a ainsi demandé au
gouvernement netanyahu de renoncer à une
annexion qui serait contraire au droit
international
la justice israélienne elle-même ne
laisse pas non plus les mains libres au
chef du likoud
la cour suprême a ainsi validé une loi
controversée permettant à israël
d'exproprier des propriétaires
palestiniens contre compensation
financière au total 450 mille colons
juifs vivent en cisjordanie occupée
et pour en parler nous sommes avec à
bahreïn
professeur agrégé à l'université st
louis de madrid bonsoir monsieur merci
d'être avec nous alors tout d'abord à
quoi doit-on s'attendre avec cette
stratégie du nouveau gouvernement
israélien
bonsoir stéphanie est bien quand on voit
le gouvernement israélien et ses
positionnements on voit qui tient le cap
par rapport aux annonces que l'on a eu
depuis le fameux plan ou le soi disant
plan tram pour la paix dans le sens où
comme vous l'a rappelé votre reportage à
partir du 1er juillet on devra avoir
cette feuille de route en fait qui
mènerait à l'annexion par israël
aussi bien de colonies en cisjordanie
que de la baie de la vallée du jourdain
dans le même temps je crois qu'il faut
bien être conscient de ce que cette
stratégie israélienne vise effectivement
à garantir l'intérêt stratégique des
israéliens et a confirmé finalement ce
que l'île est ce que beaucoup
d'israéliens ce que n'atteignant ou à
tout le moins le considèrent comme un
droit inné pour israël à savoir le fait
qu'il pourrait annexer les colonies
parce qu'ils considèrent que ces
colonies israéliennes sont des
propriétés israélienne de plein droit
mais on voit bien que dans le même temps
la donne ne sera pas plus facile c'est à
dire que bien sûr des israéliens sont
habitués à donner des coups de force
hu a forcé justement quitte à contredire
le droit international ou à contredire
l'endroit nationale comme le montre
cette pour cette décision de la cour
suprême israélienne d'invalider une loi
de 2010 est qui qui traitait de cette
question de la de l'âme de l'annexion ou
de la deûle expropriations de propriétés
palestiniennes
mais je crois que la donne diplomatique
n'est quand même pas facile pour les
israël et donc en ce sens là on va avoir
un effet d'annonce un effet d'annonce
assez fort mais je crois que les
israéliens ont quand même calculé un peu
leur pas avant que de vraiment confirmé
une annexion pure et franche comme on
semble le croire pour l'instant alors
effectivement l'europe l'entente d'une
autre oreille avec l'allemagne
en tête qui ne manque pas d'audace lors
de cette visite et qui fait clairement
savoir son opposition à ce plan
américain quelle est votre réaction
c'est vrai que l'allemagne
voilà manque pas de panache en tout cas
sûre dans cette situation bien sûr bon
alors l'allemagne déjà a développé ces
dernières années une forte stratégie
moyenne-orientale prise dans sa
globalité on a l'impression qu'elle veut
peser de plus en plus qu'elle va avoir
sa voix surtout dans un contexte dans
lequel certains pays peuvent avoir des
difficultés à un endroit où l'autre de
la région
dans le même temps regardez bien les
propos du midi affaires étrangères
allemand
il n'a pas dit non plus que l'allemagne
elle-même prendrait des sanctions si
cela arrivait il s'est plutôt réfugiés
derrière des pressions qui seraient
exercées de la part de certains états
dont on croit comprendre que ce serait
des états européens si jamais les
israéliens abondé dans le sens d'une
d'une annexion de propriétés
palestiniennes mais cela étant dit le
gros problème que l'on a c'est que
l'union européenne elle même en tant que
telle elle n'arrive pas à peser et ce
n'est en rien nouveau bien sûr
concernant les 27 états membres de
l'union européenne
on sait bien que certains d'entre eux
peuvent avoir une opinion publique qui
est plutôt opposés à une annexion des
droits des palestiniens par les
israéliens
mais dans le même temps au niveau
gouvernemental
on compte sur les doigts doigts d'une
main les pays européens qui vraiment
serait prêt à se risquer on va dire à
l'adoption de sanctions de de la sorte
c'est pourquoi je crois que l'on joue il
y à quelques parcelles de poids des
opinions publiques qui joue au niveau
européen l'allemagne elle-même qui va
présider l'union européenne à partir du
1er juillet se doit de montrer une
certaine voie en disant qu' elle ne peut
pas validé quelque chose qui contredit
le droit international mais franchement
dans le même temps je crois que tout
s'organise comme si quelque part les
israéliens veulent plutôt montré une
position de force mais seront quand même
obligé de prendre ou de faire quelqu'un
quelques calculs de manière à ménager
aussi bien l'avoir allemande que
d'autres aux européennes
justement c'était ma prochaine question
vous l'avez très bien expliqué vous
doutez de cette marge de manoeuvre que
l'europe en tout cas puisse peser
mais dans le même temps israël va
peut-être devoir faire des compromis
qu'elles peuvent être la nature de ces
compromis est ce que ça va être
finalement pardonnez moi l'expression
des cacahuètes ou quand même ça va être
sur des éléments qui vont tout de même
être significatif alors déjà là où les
israéliens veulent quand même joué
contre le temps ces dans l'anticipation
des élections présidentielles
américaines bien sûr parce que bon de
6,32 reconduits sont plutôt tranquilles
dans une quelconque que dans une
quelconque déclaration dans une
quelconque heures lens est forte mais
qui parce que celle-là scandalise la
communauté internationale aux membres de
la communauté internationale mais
maintenant dans le même temps je crois
que sur le plan des pas à adopter et sur
le plan des critères qui sont à évaluer
concernant ces différentes ces
différents positionnements
une fois encore je crois que les
israéliens effectivement se voit une
fille née à l'horizon de quelques années
comme ayant effectivement cadres et
finalement ceux qui considèrent devoir
relever du territoire du territoire
israélien mais restons conscients quand
même de ce que le jeu diplomatique peut
aller dans un sens comme dans l'autre
et moi je continue à croire que les
critères du droit international aussi
bafouée soit il sur le terrain les
critères du droit international quand
même répondre à quelques garde-fous qui
font qu une annexion franche et brutale
de cette manière est quand même quelque
chose qui qui qui qui ne devrait pas
pouvoir arriver de manière aussi facile
une fois encore malgré les déclarations
malgré les apparences on veut que le
droit international
préval quel peut être le rôle justement
de l'onu dans tout ça bon alors le nuc
en tant que tel on peut avoir un grand
débat sur sa réforme sur le conseil de
sécurité sur le fait qu'il y ait
beaucoup de limites à son action le veto
américain comme tel est quelque chose
qui garantit aussi pas mal de forces à
israël dans six positionnement
diplomatique cela étant dit une chose
intéressante c'est que puisqu'on parlait
de l'union européenne si on venait à
prendre le positionnement des états
héros des états européens sur la
question israélo palestinienne au sein
de l'assemblée générale des
nations-unies et bien une forme
majorité des pays européens sont plutôt
en faveur de la création d'un état
palestinien est plutôt opposés aux
différences politiques développées par
les israéliens vis-à-vis des
palestiniens mais étant donné que leur
posture se rabat sur d'un côté le
quatuor qui composent le bureau qui
composée d'urnes entre autres de l'union
européenne et des états unis
de l'autre côté ils ont un
positionnement qui passe à travers une
union européenne qui elle-même n'est pas
un acteur étatique traditionnelle et
bien on voit que quand il s'agit de
principes sont les expriment haut niveau
de l'assemblée générale des nations
unies mais par contre quand il s'agit de
décisions fortes à prendre on voit que
la rhétorique peut être plus ou moins
forte de temps en temps mais
malheureusement dans la réalité les
faits c'est le conseil de sécurité des
nations-unies qu'est finalement fait la
différence sur beaucoup de décisions et
ce conseil de sécurité des nations unies
lui-même est soumis à des rapports de
force qui finalement ne permettent pas
vraiment de faire avancer les choses
merci barah mikaïl d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france
merci à vous et c'est la fin de cette
émission on se retrouve donc quelques
minutes à 22 heures pile pour un point
complet sur l'actualité de ce mercredi
restent élevés
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
mais on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un font 42
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie de catastrophe
ça veut dire à côté 14 ce trop fine il
ya un tournant mais on refermait à vivre
mais dans une autre direction c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de